mayor of opinion thank you for hosting
us here in Helsinki and in this
absolutely magnificent City Hall and
Mika my thanks to you and also to your
entire Team all the researchers at the
Finish Institute of international
affairs
for deepening the scholarship about
diplomacy and also enriching the public
debate
I'm also gratified that my friend and my
partner Pekka Visto is here with us
today we have worked so closely together
over this past truly historic year and
I'm grateful for your presence
to all the distinguished guests
um two months ago
I stood with our allies in Brussels as
finland's flag was raised over NATO
headquarters for the first time
president anisto declared and I quote
the era of military non-alignment in
Finland has come to an end
a new era begins
it was a sea change that would have been
Unthinkable a little more than a year
earlier
before Russia's full-scale invasion of
Ukraine one in four Finns supported the
country joining NATO
after the full-scale invasion three in
four fins supported joining
it wasn't hard for Finns to imagine
themselves
in the Ukrainian shoes
they'd walked in them in November 1939
when the Soviet Union invaded Finland
like President Putin's so-called Special
Operation against Ukraine
the ussr's so-called Liberation
operation
falsely accused Finland of provoking The
Invasion
like the Russians with Kiev the Soviets
were confident that they'd sack Helsinki
in weeks
so confident that they had Dmitry
shashikovich composed music for the
Victory Parade before the winter War
even started
like Putin and Ukraine when Stalin
failed to overcome the Finn's Fierce and
determined resistance
he shifted to a strategy of Terror
incinerating entire villages
and bombing so many hospitals from the
air
that Finn started covering up the Red
Cross Insignia on their rooftops
like the millions of Ukrainian refugees
today
hundreds of thousands of Finns were
driven from their homes by the Soviet
invasion
they included two children fear Cohen
Henry
whose families evacuated their homes in
corellia
the mother and father of our host the
mayor of the city
to many Finns the parallels between 1939
and 2022 Were Striking
they were visceral
and they were not wrong
Finn's understood that if Russia
violated the core principles of the U.N
Charter sovereignty
territorial Integrity Independence if
they did that in Ukraine
it will imperil their own peace and
security as well
we understood that too
that's why over the course of 2021
as Russia ratcheted up its threats
against Kiev
and amassed more and more troops tanks
and planes on Ukraine's borders we made
every effort to get Moscow to
de-escalate its manufacture crisis and
resolve its issues through diplomacy
President Biden told President Putin
that we were prepared to discuss our
mutual security concerns
the message that I reaffirmed repeatedly
including in person with foreign
minister lavrov
we offered written proposals to reduce
tensions
together with our allies and partners we
used every Forum to try to prevent War
from the nato-russia council to the osce
from the U.N to our direct channels
across these engagements
we set out two possible paths from
Moscow
a path of diplomacy
which could lead to Greater security for
Ukraine for Russia for all of Europe
or a path of regression
which would result in severe
consequences for the Russian government
President Biden made clear that
regardless of which past President Putin
chose we would be ready
and if Russia chose War we would do
three things
support Ukraine
impose severe costs on Russia
and strengthen NATO
while rallying our allies and partners
around these goals
as the storm clouds gathered
we surge military economic and
humanitarian assistance to Ukraine
first in August 2021 and again in
December we send military equipment to
bolster Ukraine's defenses including
javelins and singers
and we deployed a team from the U.S
cyber command to help Ukraine Shore up
its power grid and other critical
infrastructure against cyber attacks
we prepared an unprecedented set of
sanctions export controls other economic
costs to impose severe and immediate
consequences on Russia in the event of a
full-scale invasion
we took steps to leave no doubt
that we and our allies would uphold our
commitment to defend every inch of NATO
territory
and we work relentlessly to Rally allies
and partners around helping Ukraine
defend itself
and denying Putin his strategic aims
since day one of his administration
President Biden has focused on
rebuilding and revitalizing America's
alliances and Partnerships knowing that
we're stronger when we work alongside
those who share our interests and our
values
in the run-up to Russia's invasion
we demonstrated the power of those
Partnerships
coordinating our planning and strategy
for potential Invasion with NATO with
the EU with the G7 and other allies and
partners from around the world
over those faithful weeks in January and
February of 2022
it became clear that no amount of
diplomatic effort was going to change
President Putin's mind
he would choose War
and so on February 17 2022
I went before the United Nations
security Council to warn the world that
Russia's full-scale invasion of Ukraine
was imminent
I set out the steps that Russia would
take
first manufacturing a pretext and then
using missiles tanks troops cyber
attacks to strike pre-identified targets
including Kiev
with the aim of toppling Ukraine's
democratically elected government
and a racing Ukraine from the map as an
independent country
we hoped we hoped to be proven wrong
unfortunately
we were right
a week after my warning to the security
Council President Putin invaded
ukrainians of all walks of life
soldiers and citizens
men and women
young and old
bravely defended their Nation
and the United States moved swiftly
decisively and in unison with allies and
partners to do exactly what we said we
do
support Ukraine
impose costs on Russia
strengthen NATO
all of this with our allies and partners
and with our Collective support Ukraine
did what it said it would do
defended its territory its independence
it's democracy
and today what I want to do is
set out this in the many other ways
Putin's war of aggression against
Ukraine has been a strategic failure
greatly diminishing Russia's power its
interests and its influence for years to
come
and I'll also share our vision of the
path to a just and Lasting peace
when you look at President Putin's
long-term strategic aims and objectives
there is no question
Russia is significantly worse off today
than it was before its full-scale
invasion of Ukraine militarily
economically
geopolitically
where Putin aimed to project strength
he's revealed weakness
where he sought to divide
he's United
what he tried to prevent
he's precipitated
that outcome is no accident
it's the direct result of the courage
and solidarity of the Ukrainian people
and the deliberate decisive Swift action
that we and our partners have taken to
support Ukraine
first
for years President Putin sought to
weaken and divide NATO under the false
claim that it posed a threat to Russia
in fact before Russia invaded Crimea in
eastern Ukraine in 2014
NATO's posture reflected a shared
conviction that conflict in Europe was
unlikely
the United States had significantly
reduced its forces in Europe since the
end of the Cold War from 315 000 in 1989
to 61 000 at the end of 2013.
many European countries spending on
defense had been declining for years
NATO's strategic Doctrine at the time
labeled Russia a partner
following Russia's invasion of Crimea in
the donbass in 2014 that tide began to
turn
allies committed to spend two percent of
GDP on defense and deployed new forces
to NATO's Eastern flank in response to
Russia's aggression
the alliance has accelerated its
transformation since Russia's full-scale
invasion
not to pose a threat or because NATO
seized conflict NATO always has been and
always will be a defensive Alliance
but Russia's aggression
threats nuclear saber rattling compelled
us to reinforce our deterrence and
defense
hours after the full-scale invasion
we activated NATO's defensive response
Force
in the weeks that followed several
allies including the United Kingdom
Germany the Netherlands Denmark Spain
France swiftly sent troops aircraft and
ships to reinforce NATO's Eastern flank
we doubled the number of ships
patrolling the North and Baltic seas and
double the number of battle groups in
the region
the United States established its first
permanent military presence in Poland
and of course
NATO added Finland as its 31st Ally and
we will soon add Sweden as the 32nd
as we head into the NATO Summit in
Vilnius
our shared message will be clear
NATO allies are committed to enhanced
deterrence and defense
to Greater and smarter defense spending
to deeper ties with indo-pacific
partners
NATO's door remains open to new members
and it will stay open
Russia's Invasion has also led the
European Union to do more
and more together with the United States
and with NATO than ever before
the EU and his member states have
provided over 75 billion dollars in
military economic humanitarian support
to Ukraine
that includes 18 billion dollars in
security assistance from air defense
systems to leopard tanks to ammunition
coordinating closely with the U.S the UK
and other partners the EU has launched
its most ambitious sanctions ever
immobilizing over half of Russia's
Sovereign assets
and European nations have taken in more
than 8 million Ukrainian refugees
most of whom have not only been granted
access to public services but also the
right to work
to study
second
for decades Moscow worked to deepen
Europe's dependence on Russian oil and
gas
since President Putin's full-scale
Invasion Europe has made a Swift and
decisive turn away from Russian energy
Berlin immediately canceled Nordstrom
too which would have doubled the flow of
Russian gas to Germany
before Putin's Invasion European
countries imported 37 percent of their
natural gas from Russia
Europe cut that by more than half in
less than a year
in 2022 EU countries generated a record
one-fifth of their electricity through
wind and solar
more electricity than the EU generated
through coal gas or any other power
source
the United States for its part more than
doubled our supply of gas to Europe and
our Asian allies Japan the Republic of
Korea also stepped up to boost your
supply
meanwhile the oil price cap that we and
our G7 Partners put in place has kept
Russia's energy in the global market
while dramatically cutting Russian
revenues
a year into its invasion Russia's oil
revenues had fallen by 43 percent
the Russian government's tax revenues
from oil and gas have fallen by nearly
two-thirds
and Moscow will not get back the markets
that it is lost in Europe
third
President Putin spent two decades trying
to build Russia's military into a modern
Force with cutting-edge weaponry
streamline command and well-trained
well-approved soldiers
Kremlin often claimed it had the second
strongest military in the world and many
believed it
today many see Russia's military as the
second strongest in Ukraine its
Equipment Technology leadership troops
strategy tactics and morale a case study
and failure
even as Moscow inflicts devastating
indiscriminate and gratuitous damage on
Ukraine and ukrainians
Russia is estimated to have suffered
more than a hundred thousand casualties
in the last six months alone
as Putin sends wave after wave of
Russians into a meat grinder of his own
making
meanwhile
sanctions and Export controls imposed by
the United States the European Union and
other partners around the world have
severely degraded Russia's War Machine
and defense exports
setting them back for years to come
Russ's Global defense partners and
customers can no longer count on
promised orders let alone spare parts
and as they witnessed Russia's poor
performance in the battlefield
they are increasingly taking their
business elsewhere
fourth
President Putin wanted to build Russia
up as a global economic power
his invasion cemented his long-running
failure to diversify Russia's economy to
strengthen his human capital to fully
integrate the country into the global
economy
today
Russia's economy is a shadow of what it
was
and a fraction of what it could have
become
had Putin invested in technology and
Innovation rather than weapons and War
Russia's foreign reserves are down by
more than half
as are profits from its state-owned
Enterprises
more than 1700 foreign companies have
reduced suspended or ended operations in
Russia since the onset of the invasion
that's tens of thousands of jobs gone
a massive flight of foreign expertise
and billions of dollars in Lost revenue
for the Kremlin
a million people have fled Russia
including many of the country's top I.T
Specialists entrepreneurs Engineers
doctors professors journalists
scientists
countless artists writers filmmakers
musicians have also left
seeing no future for themselves in a
country where they can't express
themselves freely
fifth
President Putin invested considerable
effort to show that Russia could be a
valued partner to China
on the eve of the invasion Beijing and
Moscow declared a No Limits partnership
18 months into the invasion that two-way
partnership looks more and more
one-sided
Putin's aggression and weaponization
strategic dependencies on Russia has
served as a wake-up call to governments
around the world to make efforts at
de-risking
and together the United States and our
partners are taking steps to reduce
those vulnerabilities
from building more resilient critical
Supply chains to strengthening our
shared tools to counter economic
coercion
so Russia's aggression hasn't distracted
us from meeting the challenges in the
indo-pacific it's actually sharpened our
focus on them
and our support for Ukraine hasn't
weakened our capabilities to meet
potential threats from China or anywhere
else it strengthened them
and we believe that Beijing is taking
notice that far from being intimidated
by a forceful violation of the U.N
Charter the world has rallied to defend
it
sixth
prior to the war
President Putin regularly used NATO
Russia's influence in international
organizations
to try to weaken the United Nations
Charter
today Russia is more isolated on the
world stage than ever
at least 140 Nations
two-thirds of U.N member states have
repeatedly voted in the U.N General
Assembly to affirm Ukraine's soverty and
territorial integrity
to reject Putin's attempts to illegally
Annex Ukrainian territory to condemn
Russia's aggression and atrocities and
to call for a peace consistent with the
principles of the United Nations Charter
governments from the West and East North
and South
have voted to suspend Russia from
numerous institutions from the U.N Human
Rights Council to the international
civil aviation organization
Russian candidates have lost one
election after another for key seats in
international institutions from the
governing board of Unicef
to leadership of the U.N agency
responsible for information and
Communications Technologies the itu
each rebuke and loss for Moscow
is not only a vote against Russia's
aggression
it's a vote for the core principles of
the United Nations Charter
and countries from every part of the
world are supporting efforts to hold
Russia accountable for its war crimes
and crimes against humanity from
creating a special U.N commission to
document the crimes and human rights
violations committed in Russia's War
two assisting investigations by
prosecutors in Ukraine and at the
international criminal court
seventh
President Putin for years sought to
divide the west from the rest
claiming that Russia was advancing the
best interests of the developing world
today
thanks to openly declaring his Imperial
Ambitions and weaponizing food and fuel
President Putin has diminished Russian
influence on every continent
Putin's efforts to reconstitute a
centuries-old Empire
reminded every nation that had endured
Colonial rule and repression of their
own pain
then he exacerbated the economic
hardship many nations were already
experiencing due to covet and climate
change by cutting off Ukraine's grain
from the world markets driving up the
cost of food and fuel everywhere
by contrast on one Global challenge
after another
the United States and our partners have
proven that our focus on Ukraine will
not distract us from working to improve
the lives of people around the world and
address the cascading costs of Russia's
aggression
our unprecedented emergency food Aid has
prevented millions of people from
starving to death
just last year alone
the United States provided 13 and a half
billion dollars in food assistance
and the United States is currently
funding over half of the U.N world food
program's budget
Russia funds less than one percent
we supported a deal negotiated by U.N
Secretary General guterres in Turkey
to break Russia's Stranglehold on
Ukrainian grain allowing 29 million tons
of food and counting to get out of
Ukraine and to people around the world
that includes eight million tons of
wheat which is the equivalent of roughly
16 billion loaves of bread
together with allies and partners
we're mobilizing hundreds of billions of
dollars in financing for high quality
infrastructure in the countries where
it's needed most and building it in a
way that's transparent
good for the environment empowers local
workers and communities
we're strengthening Global Health
security from training half a million
health professionals in our own
hemisphere in the Americas to helping
the pharmaceutical company moderna
finalize plans with Kenya to build its
first mRNA vaccine manufacturing
facility in Africa
time and again
we are demonstrating who fuels Global
problems
and who solves them
finally
President Putin's core aim
indeed his obsession
has been to erase the very idea of
Ukraine
its identity
it's people it's culture
it's agency
it's territory
but here too
Putin's actions have precipitated the
opposite effect
no one has done more to strengthen
Ukraine's national identity than the man
who sought to wipe it out
no one has done more to deepen
ukrainian's unity and solidarity
no one has done more to intensify
ukrainian's determination to write their
own future on their own terms
Ukraine will never be Russia
Ukraine stands
sovereign
independent
firmly in control of its own destiny
in this
Putin's primary goal he has failed most
spectacularly
President Putin constantly claims that
the United States Europe and countries
that support Ukraine
are bent on defeating or destroying
Russia
on toppling its government
on holding back its people
that is false
we do not seek to overthrow the Russian
government and we never have
Russia's future is for Russians to
decide
we have no problem with the Russian
people who had no say in starting this
tragic War
we lament that Putin is sending tens of
thousands of Russians to their deaths in
a war he could end now if he chose
and inflicting ruinous impact on
Russia's economy and its prospects
indeed it must be asked how has Putin's
War improved the lives the livelihoods
or the prospects of ordinary Russian
citizens
everything that we and our allies and
partners do in response to Putin's
Invasion has the same purpose
to help Ukraine defend its sovereignty
its territorial integrity and
Independence and to stand up for the
international rules and principles that
are threatened by Putin's ongoing War
let me say this directly to the Russian
people
the United States is not your enemy
the peaceful end of the Cold War
we shared the hope that Russia would
emerge to a brighter future
free and open
fully integrated with the world
for more than 30 years
we work to pursue stable and Cooperative
relations with Moscow because we believe
that a peaceful secure and prosperous
Russia is in America's interests indeed
in the interests of the world
we still believe that today
we cannot choose your future for you and
we won't try to do so
but we also will not let President Putin
impose his will on other nations
Moscow must treat the independence the
sovereignty the territorial Integrity of
its neighbors with the same respect that
it demands for Russia
now
as I've made clear by virtually every
measure
President Putin's invasion of Ukraine
has been a strategic failure
yet while Putin has failed to achieve
his aims
he hasn't given up on them
he's convinced that he can simply
Outlast Ukraine and its supporters
sending more and more Russians to their
deaths inflicting more and more
suffering on Ukraine civilians
he thinks that even if he loses the
short game
he can still win the long game
Putin is wrong about this too
the United States together with our
allies and partners is firmly committed
to supporting Ukraine's defense today
tomorrow
for as long as it takes and in America
this support is bipartisan
and precisely because we have no
Illusions about Putin's aspirations we
believe the prerequisite for Meaningful
diplomacy and real peace is a stronger
Ukraine capable of deterring and
defending against any future aggression
we've rallied a formidable team around
this effort
with Secretary of Defense Austin's
leadership more than 50 countries are
cooperating through the Ukraine defense
contact group
and we're leading by the power of our
example providing tens of billions of
dollars in security assistance to
Ukraine with robust and unwavering
support from both sides of the aisle in
our Congress
today America and our allies and
partners are helping meet Ukraine's
needs on the current Battlefield
while developing a force that can deter
and defend against aggression for years
to come
that means helping build a Ukrainian
military of the future
with long-term funding a strong Air
Force centered on Modern Combat aircraft
an integrated air and missile defense
network Advanced tanks and armored
vehicles
National capacity to produce ammunition
and the training and support to keep
forces and Equipment combat ready
that also means Ukraine's membership in
NATO will be a matter for allies and
Ukraine not Russia to decide
the path to peace will be forged not
only through Ukraine's long-term
military strength
but also the strength of its economy
and its democracy
this is at the heart of our vision for
the way forward Ukraine must not only
survive
it must thrive
to be strong enough to deter and defend
against aggressors Beyond its borders
Ukraine needs a vibrant prosperous
democracy within its borders
that's the path the Ukrainian people
voted for when they won their
independence in 1991. it's the choice
they defended in the midon in 2004 and
again in 2013
a free and open Society with respect for
human rights in the rule of law fully
integrated with Europe
where all ukrainians have dignity and
the opportunity to realize their full
potential
and where the government responds to the
needs of his people
not those of vested interests and Elites
we are committed to working with allies
and partners to help ukrainians make
their vision
a reality
will not only help Ukraine rebuild its
economy
but reimagine it with new Industries
trade routes Supply chains connected
with Europe and with markets around the
world
we'll continue to bolster Ukraine's
independent anti-corruption bodies a
free and vibrant press Civil Society
organizations
we'll help Ukraine overhaul its energy
grid
more than half of which has been
destroyed by Russia
and do it in a way that's cleaner
more resilient more integrated with its
neighbors so that Ukraine can one day
become an energy supporter
Ukraine's greater integration with
Europe is vital to all of these efforts
he took a giant step in that direction
last June when the union formally
granted Ukraine EU Canada status
and key was working to make progress
toward the eu's benchmarks even as it
fights for its survival
investing in Ukraine's strength is not
at the expense of diplomacy
paves the way for diplomacy
president zelenski said repeatedly that
diplomacy is the only way to end this
war and we agree
in December he put forward a vision for
a just and Lasting peace
instead of engaging on that proposal or
even offering one of his own
President Putin has said there's nothing
to talk about
until Ukraine accepts and I quote new
territorial realities in other words
except Russia's seizure of 20 percent of
Ukraine's territory
Putin spent the winter trying to freeze
Ukrainian civilians to death and then
the spring trying to bomb them to death
day after day
Russia Rains Down missiles and drones
on Ukrainian apartment buildings schools
hospitals
now from a distance
it's easy to become numb
to these and other Russian atrocities
like the Drone Strike last week on a
medical clinic in denipro which killed
four people including doctors
or the 17 strikes on Kiev in the month
of May alone many using Hypersonic
missiles
or the missile attack in April
on the city of uman
hundreds of miles from the front lines
in which 23 civilians were killed
the Rockets strike hit multiple
apartment buildings in uman Before Dawn
in one of those buildings a father
dimitro raced to the room where his
children were sleeping
turillo age 17.
Sophia age 11.
but when he opened the door to their
bedroom
there was no room
just fire and smoke
his children were gone
two more innocent lives extinguished
two of the six children Russia killed in
a single strike
two of the thousands of Ukrainian
children killed by Russia's war of
aggression
thousands more have been wounded
and thousands beyond that have been
abducted from their families by Russia
and given to Russian families
Millions have been displaced
all are part of a generation of
Ukrainian children
terrorized
traumatized
scarred
by Putin's war of aggression
all of whom remind us why ukrainians are
so fiercely committed to defending their
Nation
and why they deserve
deserve a just and Lasting peace
now some have argued that if the United
States truly wanted peace we'd stop
supporting Ukraine
and that if Ukraine truly wanted to end
the war it would just cut its losses and
give up a fifth of its territory that
Russia illegally occupies
let's play this out for a minute
what neighbors of Russia would feel
confident in their own sovereignty and
territorial Integrity if Putin's
aggression were to be rewarded with a
fifth of Ukraine's territory
and for that matter how would any
country that lives near a bully with a
history of threats and aggression feel
secure within its own borders
what lesson will other would be
aggressors around the world learn if
Putin is allowed to violate a core
tenant of the U.N Charter with impunity
and how often in history have aggressors
who seize all or part of a neighbor a
neighboring country
been satisfied
and stopped there
when has that ever satisfied Vladimir
Putin
the United States has been working with
Ukraine
and allies and partners around the world
to build consensus around the core
elements of a just and Lasting peace
to be clear
the United States welcomes any
initiative that helps bring President
Putin to the table to engage in
meaningful diplomacy we'll support
efforts whether by Brazil by China or
any other Nation if they help find a way
to adjust the lasting peace consistent
with the principles of the United
Nations Charter
here's what that means
a just lasting peace must uphold the U.N
Charter and affirm the principles of
sovereignty territorial integrity and
Independence
a just and Lasting peace requires
Ukraine's full participation and ascent
nothing about Ukraine without Ukraine
a Justin lasting peace must support
Ukraine's reconstruction recovery with
Russia paying its share
a Justin lasting peace must address both
accountability
and Reconciliation
a just and Lasting peace can open a
pathway to sanctions relief connected to
concrete actions especially military
withdrawal
a just and Lasting peace must end
Russia's war of aggression
now over the coming weeks and months
some countries will call for a ceasefire
and on the surface
that sounds sensible
attractive even
after all
who doesn't want warring parties to lay
down their arms who doesn't want the
killing to stop
but a ceasefire that simply freezes
current lies in place and enables Putin
to consolidate control over the
territory he seized and then rest rearm
and re-attack that is not a just and
Lasting peace it's a potemkin piece it
would legitimize Russian's land grab it
would reward the aggressor
and punish the victim
if and when Russia is ready to work for
true peace the United States will
respond in concert with Ukraine and
other allies and partners around the
world
and along with Ukraine and allies and
partners we would be prepared to have a
broader discussion on European security
that promotes stability and transparency
and reduces the likelihood of future
conflict
in the weeks and months ahead
the United States will continue to work
with Ukraine with our allies and
partners and any and all parties
dedicated to supporting a just and
Lasting peace based on these principles
on April 4
1949.
74 years to the day before Finland
joined NATO
the original members of The Alliance
gathered in Washington to sign his
founding treaty
President Truman warned the group and I
quote
we cannot succeed if our people are
haunted by the constant fear of
aggression
and burdened by the cost of repairing
their Nations individually against
attack
we hope to create a shield against
aggression and the fear of aggression a
bulwark which will permit us to get on
with the real business
of achieving a Fuller and happier life
for all of our citizens
the same is true today
no Nation
not Ukraine not the United States not
Finland Sweden any other country can
deliver for its people if it lives in
constant fear of aggression
that's why we've all got a stake
in ensuring that President Putin's war
of aggression against Ukraine continues
to be a strategic failure
in his new year's address to the Finnish
people
president ministo identified one of the
fundamental flaws of President Putin's
plan to swiftly conquer Ukraine a flaw
that also Dooms Stalin's plan
swiftly conquer Finland
as president anisto said and I quote
As Leaders of a country under
authoritarian rule
Stalin and Putin fail to recognize that
people living in a free country have
their own will and convictions
and that a nation that works together
constitutes an immense Force
Finns have a word for that Fierce
combination of Will and determination
sisu and they recognize sisu in the
struggle of ukrainians today
and when a free people like the
ukrainians have at their backs the
support of free Nations around the world
Nations who recognize their faiths and
freedoms their rights and security are
inextricably bound together
the force they possess is not merely
immense
it is Unstoppable
thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign